spoil rich kids are traveling the world
to volunteer in poor countries wow
sounds Noble right but the reality
instead of helping them these sport rich
kids often end up inadvertently
destroying these poor communities also
they can feel better about themselves
let me explain you're being sold is the
idea that you'll help a community what
you're really buying is an opportunity
to help yourself I wanted to physically
go out to be that change make a
difference be a global citizen I
definitely was thinking about how it
would look when I applied to college and
how I would look on my resume so you're
a tourism company and you want to make
more money the problem is tourism taking
vacations is often viewed as a nice to
have it would be nice if I blew a bunch
of money on a vacation but I don't need
to so if you want to make more money as
a tourism company you need to find a way
to turn this nice to half into a
must-have I have to pay thousands of
dollars for this trip but how do you do
that enter voluntourism
offering Rich Kids the opportunity to
travel to poor countries to volunteer
you could be planting trees in Brazil
teaching kids English in Kenya cleaning
up beaches in Bali or even building
houses for poor families in the
Philippines that way not only do you get
to travel to exciting Faraway places but
you also get to do so with a clean
conscience without feeling like you're
this Rich out of touch Westerner
exploiting poor people think of it as
selling an all-inclusive dose of
self-righteousness all for the small
price of a few thousand dollars and boo
now that's a business model on top of
that what's great about the voluntourism
model is that the moment people here
volunteering it automatically conjures
off images of selfless people working
tirelessly to make the world a better
place when in reality using the guise of
volunteer work and charity is a great
way to take people's money and divert it
into your own pocket that's exactly why
the volunteer tourism business has
become one of the most profitable and
Shady sectors of the travel industry
bringing in three billion dollars yearly
from millions of affluent Travelers who
are none the wiser and every year it's
only getting more and more popular and
that would be fine if the voluntourism
industry was actually making the
positive impact it claims when in
reality the billion dollar volunteerism
industry is actually an unregulated
nightmare that's destroying the local
communities is supposed to be serving
with every volunteer tourist it puts on
the ground
stay dangerous and this is the billion
dollar business of volunteerism
[Music]
although I will never be able to travel
to China by the time you're watching
this I'll actually be taking my parents
on a trip back to Vietnam they're
finally retired and haven't been back in
decades I haven't been back since I was
a little kid so this is a really
meaningful trip for us that you guys
helped make possible we've really come
full circle from immigrating to America
dirt poor to where I'm at now so I
wanted to treat them with this trip and
I highly recommend you guys keep working
super hard so you too can support your
parents as well it is extremely
rewarding we'll also be traveling to
other Southeast Asian countries while
we're out there like Indonesia but the
problem is I don't know any Indonesian
but luckily that is where Babel comes in
Babel is one of the top language
learning apps in the entire world and
what I love about Babel is that they get
straight to teaching you practical stuff
that you would actually need to say in
real life and one of the languages they
offer is Indonesian
foreign
[Music]
Babel's lessons are designed by real
language teachers and their methods are
so effective that Babel is
scientifically proven by academics from
places like Yale University to help you
start speaking a new language in just
three weeks with just a few minutes a
day over 10 million people have already
used Babel and they even offer a 20-day
money-back guarantee learning a new
language is also great for impressing
girls or a potential business client
wink wink so what are you waiting for
make 2023 the year you learn a new
language and get 60 off your Babel
subscription by clicking the link below
so pause the video and click the link
below right now for 60 off your Babel
subscription thanks to Babel for
sponsoring this video
It's probably hard to imagine
volunteering abroad as being a bad thing
but there's a big difference between
volunteering in the traditional sense
and the Twisted world of voluntourism
back in the day volunteers would
actually have to commit to years of
service where organizations like the
Peace Corps that way they will get the
training and experience needed to do
things like teach English effectively or
give Medical Care in poor communities
these real volunteers have to literally
drop everything in their lives to
dedicate their entire existence to
volunteering they do this because
they're actually doing good and it's
incredibly rewarding for them the only
problem is only a tiny handful of people
are willing to go to this extreme
however everyone wants to feel that same
feeling of contribution everyone wants
to feel that same sense of purpose even
if temporary so that is what you want to
sell you get to experience all the same
fussy feelings a real Peace Corps
volunteer gets but without all the hard
work without all the dedication just do
it for a week or a month and boom you're
in and out of that Third Ward hellhole
and you're back into your cushy life
with the Instagram pictures report
colored kiss prove it volunteer tourists
get to pick a fun rewarding activity
that they're told will improve the
country they're visiting by teaching
kids in a Tanzanian City for 1800 or
working in an animal shelter in the
Amazon for almost three thousand dollars
or doing ocean conservation in South
Africa for the bargain price of 3.2
thousand dollars without having to do
any trading undergo any background
checks or needing any special skills to
participate but what they do need is
money
volunteers and trips come with a pretty
healthy price tag of anywhere from one
thousand to seven thousand dollars
depending on the experience and where is
all this money going well almost none of
it goes to these struggling communities
that these programs are supposed to be
helping in one popular voluntourism
program only nine dollars per week of
that multi thousand dollar fee went back
into helping the community and the rest
of that money is going right into the
voluntourism company's Pockets like in
2010 when projects abroad one of the
biggest volunteerism companies out there
made over three million dollars in
profit one million of which went to the
company's two directors think about it
that is how genius this business model
is rich kids and their parents are
literally paying you thousands upon
thousands of dollars to go to a third
world country to do manual labor aside
from the Transportation costs there are
literally no overhead expenses to this
business just drop them off pick them
back up and boom you just made a few
thousand dollars per volunteer
volunteerism is not philanthropy it is a
business and a very clever business at
that and all that money is just one of
the problems with the volunteerism
industry
so let's say you're a kid you've got
affluent parents and you have them book
a volunteerism trip for you you want to
help people around the world in the most
Hands-On way possible and plus making
your resume look a little better is a
nice bonus what's the problem with this
why is it so bad it's because once the
volunteerism company gets Daddy's Money
there's no incentive to actually help
the community the only incentive is to
make you feel like you're helping to
make you feel like you're giving back to
the people so that you go home and brag
about it to all your friends so they
sign up too which is why voluntourism
often leaves these places a lot worse
off than how they found it most of the
projects that volunteers work on are
very serious and require special
training like taking care of kids who
have endured serious trauma or
constructing homes or structures that
are supposed to last a lifetime these
young inexperienced volunteers simply
don't have the skills needed to get
these jobs done properly but fear nuts
just have these kids lay down some
bricks or whatever so they feel good and
when they inevitably mess up the local
people will just have to work twice as
hard to redo all their work so all right
you take all the money and the locals
end up having to do even more labor the
primary goal of our time at the
orphanage was to build a library we
believed that we'd be able to build the
whole thing while we were there until
you realized that none of us had ever
done any construction work I realized
that they were taking apart what we'd
done and redoing it and then they'd let
it set and by the time that we would
show up to work in a few more hours we'd
be none the wiser
I told one of the chaperones from my
school on the trip about what I'd seen
and was advised to keep it to myself and
when the locals aren't redoing the work
their jobs are being taken away by these
volunteers the thing is I have never
done any teaching yeah I understand so
you can you can tell it's important here
because
of Henry the fact of the matter is it
would have been way more useful if these
volunteers would have just simply given
the money they paid to the volunteerism
company to the actual locals that two
thousand dollars that tourists pay for a
volunteer vacation would pay the salary
of an experienced Village teacher for
four months but there's nothing
heartwarming or exciting about just
donating money which is why millions of
people still have to spend thousands of
dollars on volunteer vacations instead
and what's the biggest demographic of
people that these unqualified volunteers
are working with extremely vulnerable
children in orphanages
foreign
children normally live at the Don Bosco
Center one of the most popular places
volunteers go to are orphanages although
orphanages are no longer a thing in
places like America in places like Nepal
Kenya Ghana Cambodia Tanzania and South
Africa there are orphanages all over the
place an orphanage voluntourism is a
huge business volunteer tourists think
who better to help them poor children
without parents most volunteers also
arrive via an increasingly
commercialized system and before leaving
home it's worth investigating who really
stands to profit from their presence but
the thing is a lot of the kids living in
these orphanages are orphans at all over
80 percent of children in orphanages
around the world have at least one
living parent according to the U.S state
Department most are placed in orphanages
because their families are too poor to
take care of them quote child finders go
into communities earner paid 50 to 100
to identify needy families End quotes
these struggling parents are promised
that their kids will get food and a good
education but what really ends up
happening is that these kids are being
placed in orphanages so that the
orphanage directors can make money from
volunteer tourists who want to take care
of these needy kids
[Music]
in these orphanages when there are no
volunteers around these children are
subjected to a painful scary and
institutionalized upbringing where they
serve as one of the country's top
tourist attractions just look at Nepal
over 90 percent of the orphanages in the
country are located right in the top
tourist districts convenient right or
Cambodia while the rest of the world is
reducing the number of orphanages the
number of them in Cambodia has doubled
and with every new orphanages costs more
money from volunteer tourists just now a
group of Canadians are visiting
in their downtime the students get to
play with the children once a child is
poached to live in a orphanage they are
completely Anonymous no identification
no birth certificate nothing nobody has
any idea who they are so it's virtually
impossible to find their family ever
again they are left completely alone
inside these orphanages directors try to
keep the conditions as terrible as
possible that way volunteers see just
how awful it is which makes them want to
give even more money the more
malnourished helpless and dirty the
children are the better it is for the
orphanage directors if they see kids
sleeping on a good bed with a good
mattress they won't donate money for
better beds and better mattresses even
though they're actually hurting children
for profit orphanages like these still
attract hundreds of millions of dollars
every year in foreign donations
orphanages are the perfect place to take
volunteers because they talks on their
heartstrings there's nothing quite as
emotionally rewarding as a bunch of
little kids running towards you with joy
as Canadians and orphans grow closer not
just Goodwill but a lot of money is
flowing into the orphanage just two but
what's actually happened is that each of
these volunteers becomes just another
person who enters these kids lives for a
week and then leaves forever it's
emotionally devastating not to mention
that the volunteers aren't vetted in any
way this is the very high risk for
Cambodian children who are living in the
orphanage this guy you know his American
guys and he came to Cambodia through
approaching abroad all they have to do
is pay a fee and they have full access
to hundreds of vulnerable children who
don't have any Identity or anyone who
truly cares about them
sticking to
you but instead we've kind of just left
there's no lump there no dreams the kids
have got nothing to do and our teacher
was totally pointless so this ends up
creating some really disturbing
situations so if orphanages are so
detrimental to kids why are there more
and more of these institutions popping
up every year the answer demand the
demand from Hungry volunteers who want
to make a difference
[Music]
foreign
tourism is poetically ironic an industry
that promises to bring much needed Aid
to struggling communities is actually
just a giant business that prioritizes
wealthy volunteers while intentionally
keeping these places in poverty there's
no oversight as to where the billions of
dollars are going no one is looking into
potential volunteers to see if they're a
threat to the vulnerable communities
they're entering and the bigger the
volunteerism industry becomes the more
difficult it is for these at-risk
communities to be self-reliant which is
exactly what the volunteerism industry
wants it's not about providing these
places with the help they need to get
out of poverty it's about keeping them
in poverty so you can send in more and
more volunteers every year each paying a
hefty fee voluntourism is completely
reliant on these de facto slaves staying
slaves and guess what pretty much every
other successful government and
Corporation are also reliant on slave
labor learn about this dark secret of
the World by watching our video with the
link below
[Music]
foreign